Epstein Island was like Disney World for
rich and powerful perverts because
non-rich, non-powerful perverts would
just go to Disney World.
Say, you want to come inside my
clubhouse?
There are only two types of people in
America. Those who wanted the Epstein
files released and those who were in the
Epstein files. But, why were so many
people interested in seeing what's in
these files?
Why was this such an important issue?
Well, when we hear about a man offering
his influential friends and
acquaintances a twisted paradise where
they can have their way with young
girls, we want to know who was involved.
And since Epstein was apparently
recording his friends and acquaintances
in compromising positions in case he
needed to blackmail them,
we want to know who was being extorted
and what they may have done to keep
Epstein happy.
But, here's what's interesting.
As sick and depraved as Epstein and his
island paradise were,
they're an absolute joke compared to
Allah and his eternal paradise.
Allah is the ultimate Epstein and you're
about to find out why.
I'm sure you've heard of the houris
Muslims will be given in paradise. These
are the virgins Muslim men will spend
eternity deflowering. We read about
these houris in several passages of the
Quran. Here's Sura 56 verses 10 to 40.
And the foremost shall be the foremost.
Wow, that's profound.
They are the ones brought nigh in
gardens of bliss, many from those of old
and few from those of later times upon
embroidered couches reclining upon them
facing one another. Immortal youths wait
upon them with goblets, ewers, and a cup
from a flowing spring wherefrom they
suffer neither headache nor stupefaction
with fruits as they choose and the meat
of birds as they desire. And there shall
be wide-eyed maidens the likeness of
concealed pearls as a recompense for
that which they used to do.
They hear no idle talk therein nor
incitement to sin save that peace, peace
is uttered. And the companions of the
right, what of the companions of the
right? Among thornless lote trees,
clustered plantains, and extended shade,
gushing water, and abundant fruit
neither out of reach nor forbidden and
upon raised beds.
Truly, we brought them into being as a
new creation, then made for them
virgins, amorous peers for the
companions of the right, many from those
of old and many from those of later
times. So, we've got the wide-eyed
maidens who will be virgins.
In his commentary on this passage, Ibn
Kathir quotes Muhammad for more detail.
The messenger of Allah said, "In
paradise, the believer will be given
such and such strength for women."
Anas said, "I asked, 'Oh Allah's
messenger, will one be able to do
that?'" He said, "He will be given the
strength of a hundred men."
Just don't ask him how you get the
strength of a hundred men, am I right?
Someone else asked, "Oh Allah's
messenger, will we have sexual
intercourse with our wives in paradise?"
He said, "The man will be able to have
sexual intercourse with a hundred
virgins in one day."
If you're wondering how Allah's not
going to run out of virgins, keep in
mind he's the best of planners. Here's
what he's going to do.
Every time you have sex with one of your
virgins, Allah will turn her back into a
virgin.
As we read in Tafsir Jalalayn, Quran
verses in bold, explanation not in bold,
"Verily, we have created them with an
unmediated creation, namely the
wide-eyed houris. We created them
without the process of birth and made
them virgins, immaculate.
Every time their spouses enter them,
they find them virgins. Nor is there any
pain of defloration."
That's thoughtful.
This is how a Muslim man can have sex
with a hundred virgins every day. Allah
keeps restoring their virginity over and
over and over forever.
But, what else do we know about these
virgins?
Turns out there's an interesting verse
of the Quran that talks about their
breasts, but the verse gets translated
in very different ways. Here's Arberry's
translation of Sura 78 verses 31 to 34.
"Surely, for the God-fearing awaits a
place of security, gardens and vineyards
and maidens with swelling breasts like
of age and a cup overflowing."
Arberry translates this as maidens with
swelling breasts. There are Muslims who
think this verse is about large, fully
developed breasts and they'll say this
means that the women are fully grown,
somewhere around 33 years of age.
But, other translations say something
quite different. Here's M. H. Shakir's
translation.
"Surely, for those who guard against
evil is achievement, gardens and
vineyards and those showing freshness of
youth, equals in age, and a pure cup."
Shakir doesn't even mention breasts. Why
is that?
Well, as Muslim scholars have explained,
Sura 78 verse 33 isn't about swelling
breasts, it's about a stage of
development.
The verse is about girls with budding
breasts. Their breasts are just starting
to form.
This is why Shakir translates it as
those showing freshness of youth who are
all the same age.
But, don't take my word for it. You can
find this in various commentaries, but
the Muslim scholars at IslamQA have put
together a nice article for us.
The article begins by pointing out that
to understand the verse, you have to
learn how the expression is used in
Arabic. Then the scholars explain,
"Based on that, we say to you that with
regard to the literal translation of the
word kawa'ib, that's the word Arberry
translated as swelling breasts because
he didn't understand how it's used in
Arabic,
it is the plural of the word ka'ib,
which refers to a female with developing
breasts. As it says in Majmal al-Lugha,
Ibn Faris, may Allah have mercy on him,
said,
'Ka'b comes from a sound root that is
indicative of a thing beginning to
develop and emerge. From the same root
comes the word ka'b, which refers to the
ankle, which is the bone on the two
sides of the lower leg where it meets
the foot. And the word Kaaba, which
refers to the house of Allah, may he be
exalted, it is so called because of its
prominence and its square shape.
A woman is described as a ka'ib when her
breasts begin to develop. And here are
some sources. This is the literal
meaning of the word in terms of
linguistic roots.
So, the word ka'ib refers to a girl
whose breasts are just starting to form
and it's related to the word ka'b, which
refers to the little bone that sticks
out on the side of your ankle.
Then the scholars give an example of
what they're talking about by showing
how the Arabic word for menstruating can
be used to mean literally menstruating
or to refer to a stage of development,
someone who's reached the age of
menstruation.
And they continue,
"We may say something similar about
describing a woman as ka'ib in Arabic.
It is not intended as an erotic physical
description of any part of the woman's
body as much as it is intended as a
description of the girl in terms of the
emergence of the signs of femininity in
her as an indication of her young age
and youthfulness so that men would be
attracted to her.
At this age, the signs of femininity
begin to appear in the girl.
The point of using this word is not to
describe the size of the breasts or to
note their form or shape. Rather, the
purpose is to highlight the woman's
youthfulness."
Ibn al-Jawzi, may Allah have mercy on
him, said, "The woman is a tiflah,
little girl, when she is small, walidah
when she begins to walk, then a ka'ib
when her breasts begin to appear, then a
nahid when they increase in size, then
mu'sir when she reaches the age of
puberty, then kha'ud when she reaches
the age of a young woman."
Did you catch that?
She's a ka'ib when her breasts begin to
appear and that's two stages before she
reaches the age of puberty.
Here they consider menstruation as the
beginning of puberty.
Why is this significant? Well, according
to their system, a kaib is a
pre-pubescent girl.
Doctors today treat budding breasts as a
sign of early puberty. Breasts begin to
form during Tanner stage two.
But in Islam, Tanner stage two is still
pre-pubescent.
What does this mean?
Well,
if the houris of paradise are all the
same age, and they're all Tanner stage
two forever,
then according to Islam, every single
Muslim man will spend eternity
deflowering pre-pubescent girls.
Allah will make sure that all of these
pre-pubescent girls are virgins every
time the Muslim men have sex with them.
And Muslim women who somehow make it to
paradise will spend eternity watching
their husbands deflower pre-pubescent
girls.
Allah is therefore the infinite Jeffrey
Epstein, and his paradise is the
infinite Epstein Island.
Actually, now that I think about it,
Muhammad was the one who was using these
promises of an infinite Epstein Island
to gain control over people. So,
Muhammad would be the infinite Jeffrey
Epstein.
Ghislaine Maxwell was the one who would
recruit the girls. So, Allah would be
more like the infinite Ghislaine
Maxwell. He's providing the girls.
But remember, one of the reasons so many
of us wanted the Epstein files released
was that we wanted to know what sort of
people were joining Epstein on his
little island.
Kind of makes you wonder what sort of
people would be drawn to Islam by
promises of an eternity of deflowering
pre-pubescent girls.
Sounds like someone needs to release
the Islam files.
Oh, wait.
They already did.
Who's driving that? Who's driving that?
Who's driving that?
It's just back firing. Who's driving
that? Who's driving that? Who's driving
that?
It's just back firing. [music] This is a
proper religion. There's a reason to it.
Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?